*intro music* dooo doo doooo
Hello Internet! Welcome to Film Theory!
Where I can't waste anymore time getting to the finale of this theory,
because I keep literally being stopped in the streets and asked what one is the deadliest movie is gonna end up being.
It's actually a little unsettling how into this theory everyone is.
Plus, the process of getting through these last 5 EXCRUCIATINGLY historically inaccurate movies
is going to take us so long that I literally don't have any time to waste today.
No witty banter, no cringey dad jokes, :((((((
Just death, death, and even more DEATH-ok.....-
Remember, we ended last episode with our total kill count sitting at three thousand, five hundred and twenty.
(I forgot to add a two at the end of last episode)
Those three thousand, five hundred twenty deaths were comin' across fifty three movies.
The top of our deadliest Disney movie leaderboard belonged to "The Lion King", (survival of the fittest am i right?)
sitting confidently atop pride rock and a pile o' bones with one thousand, six hundred and sixty lives lost, (oh snap!)
mostly due to a half a decade of hyenas overfeeding.
But get ready because today's challengers are gonna give that number a heck of a run for its money.
When we started in on this trilogy,
everyone on our Theorist Team picked the movie that
they thought was gonna end up being the deadliest.
It's like guessing the weight
of a new baby before it's born,
except instead of pounds and ounces, it's
beheadings and extinction-level events! (I wonder what system this measurement this is!)
Hopefully, your pick made it as a
finalist because this is your last chance to get those bets in!
Your final five, Internet:
Mulan, Dinosaur, Hercules, Atlantis or Moana! (Mulan is by far the deadliest in my eyes)
Or heck,  maybe it's just gonna stay "The Lion King". (maybe!)
Choose wisely,
because
lives, and more importantly, internet bragging rights, depend on it.
Let's start
with what is bizarrely the most straightforward of these final five:
Mulan
which was a clear fan favorite for death count in the comments.
And I understand why.
I mean, you literally see two villages burned,
an army of good guys
just outright dead in the snow,
and the climax of the whole thing is,
as we all remember,
Mulan using fireworks to cause an avalanche,
that buries all but six of
the invading Hun army. (ThaT's alOt of dAmaGe!)
Initially, I thought the best way to do this would be
to just look at history. (History saves da day!)
Mulan the Disney movie, in case you
didn't know,
comes from the Chinese legend of Hua Mulan,
where the female
warrior, Mulan, does what the movie would teach us to expect her to do,
she takes
her aging father's place in the army to defend against invaders.
Interestingly enough, though, this is a really progressive story.
In the original
legend, she doesn't hide her true self
from her family, or sneak away in the
middle of the night.
Her family totally supports her decision to become a
kick-butt warrior woman. (who wouldn't?)
And she doesn't even need to fall in love with another soldier.
I mean, I get that Disney needed to create some conflict or something,
but the 5th century historical version of this story is actually a lot cooler, (cooler than that avalanche?)
and
a lot more progressive than the 1998 remake.
Feels bad man. D': (KERMIT NOOOOOOOO)
Given that it's a
legend, maaaaaaaybe based in some history,
I thought we could estimate deaths based
on the number of soldiers in Shan Yu's real army. (He was real?!!)
Buuuuuuuut Shan Yu isn't a real person. (Oh ok! Almost had a brain-splosion there)
If anyone, he's sort of super loosely based on Attila the Hun,
but geographically, Attila's Empire ended 3,000 miles west of the Northern Wei
Empire,
where the Mulan legend originates.
And most of his battles were fought
against Europeans.
So we got ourselves the wrong enemy,
at the wrong end of the continent.
So there were really no Attila battles that I could base this on.
But, I kept on trying (You always do!)
Shan Yu gets his name from the anglicized version of Chanyu title,
which is just the generic term for a Hun leader.
It would be like watching a
movie about America a thousand years from now,
where the head of our country
was somehow named Perez O'Dent!
Given that Chanyu is this totally generic title,
there is still no battle that we could possibly base this finale of Mulan on.
It also doesn't help us that there's no real historical record of Mulan. (whAaaAaAaAaAaAaaAaT?)
While her legend is really famous, she's usually left out of Chinese history texts (probs cause she was a woman)
and seems to be treated like a symbol rather than a real historical person.(ok nevermind)
So in the end, with not enough credible information to go on,
I had to result to doing a death count the old-fashioned way: counting.
Except that counting all these people
the old-fashioned way would have taken a
ridiculous amount of time,
so I did it the new fashioned way: a Macro.
Using
GNU Octave,
I processed the frames of Mulan to automatically count how large Shan Yu's horde was.
The program converts the images into black and white,
which, in turn, makes it easier for the computer to count the individual members of the army.
I had to really fiddle around with the settings here,
to make sure that the program only was counting what I wanted it to,
soon to be dead Huns.
After some creative photoshopping,
I came out with eleven deaths on the
mountainside by aggressive firework,
plus an additional hundred and seventy-eight horsemen,
and one thousand and forty-eight other soldiers in the avalanche itself, (oh snap!)
for a grand total of one thousand, two hundred and thirty-seven kills.
Add to that the two villages that we see burned,
which, based on the size and proximity to the Great Wall of China,
would have had about a hundred residents each.
As well as the army that gets
massacred trying to surprise attack Shan Yu,
which we can count in these scenes
to be thirty-one,
but actually only adds thirty deaths,
since one messenger survives the
massacre.
"How many men does it take to deliver a message?"
*Awkward silence*
"One..."
And then Shan Yu
himself,
we get ourselves a grand total of one thousand, four hundred and sixty-eight.
It's worth noting here that I've
seen a few other different versions of this death count circulating around online,
ranging anywhere from two hundred and sixty,
to the upwards of two thousand.
I was
as absolutely exhaustive in this analysis as possible,
so I feel pretty darn good about that one thousand four-hundred and sixty-eight number,
but in the end, it still doesn't edge out The Lion King.
With
Mulan out of the way, (Nuuuuuu)
it's time to move on to the last of our movies in the princess category.
Going from Mulan in China-ish to Moana in Polynesia-ish.
After this, it's all gods and natural disasters,
so Moana is gonna be our last hope for a princess to take home the murder crown.
Grandma Tala becomes
death number one early on in the movie,
and death number two quickly skyrockets
to death number two hundred and sixty,
when Maui and Moana blow up and sink an entire society of Kakamora,
the little coconut pirates they meet,
in that totally forgettable scene that's just sandwiched in the middle of the movie.
Anyway, those little
scamps are based on a Solomon Islands legend of the Kakamora,
a race of very small people who would steal from island tribes.
They're always
depicted as cute and harmless.
Which is clearly why Moana and Maui feel it necessary to sink two hundred and fifty-nine of them,
at my best count, mercilessly into the ocean,
and then smile about it to each other as they sail away,
leaving no survivors in their wake.
"We did it!"
Ba-rutal!
Okay, that's two hundred and sixty.
It's certainly a bloodbath, but it is far from record-breaking,
but now we get to the curse.
The whole movie hinges on the fact that Maui stole this powerful heart of Te Fiti,
and thereby brought about a thousand-year plague.
"Without her heart,
Te Fiti began to crumble, giving birth to a terrible darkness, (Darkrai is that you?)
that will continue to spread until every one of us is devoured by inescapable death!"
That means that Maui would be
responsible for a thousand years of darkness spreading across the Pacific Islands,
which seems like it should be a shoo-in for death and destruction.
I am certainly excited. >:D
Now we do have to remember that except for a single crab god,
animal species aren't sapient in this movie.
So fish aren't gonna count.
And as much as I'd like to think that that leaves us with plenty of room for death,
the problem with this curse quickly becomes the fact that it's just now showing up to Moana's island
which means that it has been coming for
a looooooong time.
Sure, Grandma's map at the beginning of
the movie shows this darkness spreading really fast,
and yet when Moana and her dad visit the top of the island,
he shows her how long they've been living there without any issues.
No darkness to contend with, for
at my count, twelve generations.
If we're being generous and say that a generation of leader is turning over every 25 years,
which again, Moana's dad looks
significantly older than this but we're
giving it a worst-case scenario,
we're looking at at least 300 years of easy fish and coconuts, without even a hint of a plague.
I mean if you have that long to become a doomsday prepper,
and you don't build in any contingency plans,
I think there's an argument to be made that you might have had it coming. (corona virus anyone?)
Anyway the point is, we need to see if this darkness is actually creeping up on anyone,
or if it's just totally avoidable.
To figure that out, we're gonna have to measure how far the curse has traveled.
Which, we know
is gonna be from the heart of Te Fiti,
where the curse started, to Moana's
Island at the start of the movie.
So all we need to know is how far she travels in her boat between those two locations
and how long it takes to get there.
Here's what we know, we see Moana travel for three, maybe four days at most,
her boat is captained by Maui,
a master wayfinder and demigod,
and her boat is a recreation of a Fijian camakau, (say: camikaw)
similar to an out-rigger canoe,
that can travel up to 15 knots,
or, 17 MPH.
We're gonna somehow have
to ignore the fact
that this boat was also built by those three hundred year old ancestors who landed on Moana's Island,
making this boat so impossibly
old that there's no way it would actually sail,
but, whatever Disney.
We'll also assume that Moana didn't sleep at any point during the journey,
something Maui considered a sign of weakness as a wayfinder. (gosh she looks bad)
So at the boats max rate,
steered completely straight by an expert wayfinder,
she could sail one thousand six-hundred and thirty-two miles,
or two thousand six-hundred and twenty-six kilometers, in four days,
which is pretty incredible but we're
giving them the best-case scenario.
This means that Moana's island is a
little over sixteen-hundred miles from the heart of Te Fiti, or curse ground zero.
So okay, if the darkness started at Te Fiti,
and is just now reaching Moana's Island at least three-hundred years later,
we're saying that it took three-hundred years for the darkness to spread sixteen hundred and thirty-two miles.
Meaning that the curse has spread 5.4
miles per year.
That is NOTHING!!
When you're standing on the shore of a beach,
the horizon you're seeing is 2.8 miles away.
From the top of Moana's Island,
you would be seeing well over 12 miles into the horizon.
You would literally see
this darkness coming towards your shores for several years in advance,
which is why Moana's deadliness just falls apart.
With that much notice,
it would be almost impossible to believe that seafaring Polynesian island dwellers,
who primarily fish for survival,
would be unable to, you know, get in their boats and sail to the next island over when they see the curse coming,
thereby buying them a few extra years.
Even Moana's tribe of people who are water-phobic are still gonna have time to see their shriveled coconuts,
throw some Flex Tape onto those centuries-old boats,
and move to the next island, which would buy them more time.
So the final death tally for Moana, two hundred and sixty-one.(OMG SO LOW)
Not. even. close.
After a thoroughly disappointing performance by Moana,
it's up to the last three movies to knock my socks off,
and I'm confident in the next two:
Atlantis: The Lost Empire and Hercules.
Sure, Atlantis: The Lost Empire ain't one of those beloved Disney classics, with a big plastic VHS cover,
but looking back on it, it's pretty darn good,
and at the very
least, it is pretty darn deadly.
But at this point, that's all I really care about.
And since "We're in the endgame now",
it's gonna need to prove itself in gladiatorial fashion,
against another strong challenger from the same part of the world, Hercules!
In one corner we've got ourself a flood that wrecks an entire civilization,
and in the other we have ourselves a complete war between gods and Titans,
with the world of man caught stuck in the middle.
So let's set up those dueling
death tickers and get down to it.
"Atlantis" there's a big chase scene with
a Leviathan early on in the movie,
that accounts for one-hundred and seventy-one deaths right off the bat. (OUCH...)
Adding in the King's death, and the ending battle, we suddenly jump up to a hundred and eighty-five.
Though it can be hard to tell how many of the explosions we see signifying certain death,
and how many
are just like,
"Pew pew pew! Boom boom! Bhlur bhlur!"
As I believe is the technical term of what we're watching. (i thought you said no banter.)
Hercules His kills are mostly taking place during the montage
of him completing some of the most famous twelve labors of Hercules.
Herc' kills the Hydra, Erymanthian boar,  the Nemean Lion which
(looks suspiciously like Scar),
a sea monster that isn't part of the labors,
but we'll give him credit for anyway,
and then the Minotaur, a Gorgon and some really scary looking bird.
Two of which were actually fought by the Greek hero Perseus, but you get the idea.
We can also give Hercules credit for killing Nessus, the Centaur that's torturing Meg.
It's unclear in the movie if he's officially dead or if he's just unconscious,
but according to Greek myth Hercules does indeed kill him, so we're gonna go with that.
and no, we're not counting Meg,
sure, she dies, but she has to die and stay dead.
Meg gets revived before the end of
the movie.
Also, you can't count Hades, because he already lives in the underworld.
So, based off of these early action sequences,
Atlantis: The Lost Empire has a significant lead,
but at the end of the day, this isn't really gonna matter.
Because these numbers are tiny, compared
to the huge catastrophic events in both movies.
The sinking of Atlantis, and the
Titanomachy.
And here's where the counting has to get creative.
Atlantis: The Lost Empire starts with a giant tsunami headed for the island of Atlantis.
A protective barrier, bubble, thing is formed around the center of the island,
and sinks into the ocean.
It's not as though everyone in Atlantis dies,
but we do see a lot of people banging on that bubble from the outside,
and the bubble only ends up saving just a small fraction of the land of Atlantis.(ouch...)
Which leaves us with an obvious question, and the not so obvious answer:
How many people die when Atlantis sinks?
It'd be nearly impossible to get a decent guess at this just from the design of the city that we see at the beginning of the movie,
so we're gonna have to go all the way back to the ancient Greek Atlantis story to determine the most likely death toll.
Ditto for when Hades releases the
Titans onto Earth and they start wrecking house.
Let's start with Atlantis.
From a historical perspective, all our information about Atlantis comes from the Greek philosopher Plato.
You know, the Plato who tells a story about a farmer who finds himself a ring
that makes him invisible but corrupts him morally.
A story that J.R.R Tolkien deeeefinitely didn't steal.
Anyway, in his dialogue
"Critias", Plato tells of the continent Atlantis,
a 10,000 BC superpower with a
great military and tons of technology,
so advanced that it sank because the gods
got jealous and sent a big earthquake/flood combo to take it down. (it's super effective!)
Sounds fine, cool myth bro, but Plato never mentions how many people live on
Atlantis,
which would have really done a lot to make my life easier.
Bizarrely, the mythical estimates for Atlantis's army ranges from 5 million to over 100 million, and everything in between.
but regardless, those numbers give us a
bit of an issue,
because the population of the entire world at the time in
10,000 BC,
would have been somewhere in the order of 1 to 3 million people!
Adding insult to injury, Atlantis probably isn't even from
10,000 BC,
because a mistranslation basically changed the entire story to nine thousand years ago,
when it was originally meant to be nine hundred
years ago.
So basically, TL;DR, we're looking for some
historical event that Plato could have based his clearly made-up story on,
that he then used to pass off as if it were historically true to all his bros.
So what historic clues can we find in Atlantis the movie?
Well, the one thing we
actually know is that there was a tsunami.
So we just have to find a
massive historical tsunami
at the right time and place to make this happen,
and for that ladies and gentlemen, I give you:
The Minoan civilization.
Located on the island of Crete and most prominent from about 2000 to 1500 BC.
The Minoans are most famous for building palaces and being the inspiration for the myth of the Minotaur,
but Minoans are also our best proxy for
both Atlantis as Plato reported it,
as well as how Disney imagined it.
The large buildings that we see present in Atlantis: the Lost Empire
would have been extraordinarily rare in the ancient world,
but the Minoans were building
palaces and multi-story buildings
earlier than any other island
civilization that we know of.
The Minoan language also checks off the boxes from what we see in the movie.
Nobody is really sure what Minoan sounded like,
because we can't read the basic Minoan writing system known as "Linear A",
which parallels the fact that no one can read Atlantean in the movie itself.
"Yes, yes, I can read Atlantean just like you."
"You can't, can you?
"No one can."
And most importantly of all, we have an event that would make sense for the "sinking" of Atlantis.
Around 1550 BC,
right around the real time Atlantis was supposed to be set without Plato screwing up his dates,
the volcanic island of Thera- modern-day Santorini,
exploded, destroying part of the island
and sending gigantic waves to the shores of Crete,
only about 70 miles away.
The resulting tsunami devastated the coast of Crete,
destroying cities, ruining coastline,
and of course killing a lot of people.
Now I hear ya, Atlantis is
supposed to have sunk into the sea,
and Crete is still very much around.
That said, part of the island of Thera sank,
you can actually see where a bunch of it
is missing even to this day.
So the whole idea is still right, for this event sunk an island and destroyed a civilization.
So for God's sake, after all of that over
analysis, what the heck is the death count?
Well, estimates have the eruption
of Thera killing 35,000 Minoans on Crete.
Wow. That's to say nothing of the people
who are on Thera itself.
Even if we want to use a more conservative estimate,
those estimates still run in the range of twenty thousand deaths.
Definitely enough to dwarf any of our other Disney contenders up to this point.
So as devastating a historical event as this was based on,
the silver lining here is that in the Disney version there is no way "Hercules" can beat this, right?
I mean, sure, houses are crushed, temples are blown away,
but it can't measure up to the explosion of Thera, right?
Except, interestingly enough, many people believe that the inspiration for the story of the Titanomachy,
the exact scenes that we see take place in Hercules, was the massive eruption of Thera.
The same event that we just attributed to the loss of Atlantis.
So the long story short here is
that the destruction in these two movies are based on the exact same event.
So what is it, like a tie, then?
I mean, effectively.
For as much as we can calculate real numbers out of poorly documented historical facts,
that influenced fictional movies hundreds of years later, yeah.
Although Hercules is taking place in Thebes, which is much farther away from Thera than Crete is,
so there would be fewer deaths associated with Hercules just by proximity alone.
There you have it. Hercules and Atlantis practically in a tie.
I mean, of the two, Atlantis would qualify as the more deadly movie,
with Hercules in second
place, but the two of them have a commanding lead
over anything else in the Disney canon that we've covered so far.
Congratulations, Disney, on leveraging a devastating global event for children's entertainment,
not just once but twice.
But don't worry, I hear ya.
"A tie? What?!"
"You can't lead us through an entire flippin' trilogy on Disney movies,
and ruin Christmas, and string us along through this ungodly long episode,
that has itself a flippin' mid-roll just to tell us that it ends in a tie!"
I mean, I don't write the movies, so take it up with old Walt.
Oh wait! There is still one more.
Dinosaur.
That's right.
The Disney feature you didn't know you needed and then definitely continue to not need,
because it came out in 2000,
and we already had the far superior Land Before Time series since 1988.
But regardless, it's a movie
that the Disney Animation Studios made,
and it is here where the buck stops when
it comes to Disney deaths.
And I know you're all like
"Oh! Of course! This movie shows the extinction, right? So many millions of dinosaurs died!",
And as much as I'd like to just finally, finally end this with the mass extinction of the dinosaurs,
this movie actually doesn't show that event.
I swear, that would have
put the easy way out!
But in the entire film, only five dinosaurs died.
Two bad guys, two good guys and one neutral Triceratops.
That's it.
I know, I couldn't
believe it either!
But if that's the case, then where else
could all the deaths come from?
And the grand answer,
the answer to where the most Disney deaths come from in the animation studio's 80-year history isn't coming from humans,
isn't coming from fish,
it's coming from lemurs.
Yep. These guys.
Prehistoric lemurs.
You might be thinking to yourself,
"Gee! I didn't think dinosaurs and lemurs really lived at the same time!"
And right you would be!
Pretty much.
There's some research that mammals and dinosaurs did overlap for a very short time at the end of the Cretaceous period,
when Aladar, our Iguanodon
protagonist, was supposed to have lived.
And it just so happens that one of the
oldest animal species to exist
in this teeny overlapping sweet spot 60 million years ago were lemurs.
And yes, historically, you still have to really
squint at this one to get any kind of scenario
where a monkey family would raise a dinosaur,
but we're just gonna have to go with this one in order to make it to the other side of it.
So, like I said,
very few dinosaurs were actually harmed in the making of "Dinosaur",
but an entire island worth of lemurs were just knocked out in one fell swoop.
We see a meteor and the associated fallout land on the uncreatively named Lemur Island in the movie,
sending the entire island up in flames,
except for this small lemur family,
and our friendly dinosaur hero.
The lemur baby
even comments that,
"They're all...gone." :( (Geez that's dark)
during the film, thereby confirming for us that every lemur on Lemur Island is now a crispy critter.
But of course that leads to the next obvious question:
How in the world do we know how many that is or even how big Lemur island is?
Well, in the most
bizarre twist of luck,
we actually know the real world location of Lemur Island,
because historically there is only one possible location.
It's the real island
off the East coast of Africa called...
Madagascar.
"I like to move it move it!"
And your biology lesson for the day:
The reason lemurs are lemurs is because they evolved all by themselves over millions of years,
isolated from all other primate species on the lonely island of Madagascar.
All lemurs, even modern lemurs, started back on Madagascar.
So this is literally the only place Lemur Island could be in the entire planet Earth,
especially on the order of 60 million years ago,
when Madagascar had just started to separate from continental Africa.
This is also why we only see the dinosaur and lemurs swimming across a narrow channel,
rather than a huge body of water,
in the aftermath of the meteor strike.
At the time they escaped from Lemur Island, Lemur Island was just recently Lemur Peninsula.
So with that incredible stroke of luck,
we now know not only where Lemur
Island is, but how big it is.
Madagascar is 226,597 square miles
in area.
But not all of that area is habitable by lemurs.
Going by its modern-day geography, which is honestly all we got,
only about 43,000 square
miles of the island is rainforest,
which is Lemur habitat and also the area where we see the lemurs living in the movies.
So how many lemurs could reasonably be
living in 43,000 square miles of jungle?
OOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
Well, this is impossible to know directly,
but the lemurs in the movie would have
been precursors to the modern ring-tailed lemur,
which has a territory size of 0.14 square miles.
That means that you could fit yourself 307,143 lemurs on to Madagascar at territory capacity,
which is how many lemurs we would have the potential to lose in Dinosaur.
Even if we said it was half
that number,
even if we said it was a tenth of that number,
we still have our winner by
a long shot.
By an apocalyptic landslide, Dinosaur is the deadliest Disney movie of all time.
Rest in peace, lemurs, in a moment of
silence for all the Disney fallen who've gone before you.
*CUE EMOTIONAL MUSIC*
So after fifty-eight movies and three incredibly long episodes,
what does all this mean, my friends?
We have come a long way on the
Disney death train. (Or the d.d. train for short!)
I wanted to highlight how much we've accomplished here by recapping some of our most significant findings.
Across the entire Disney canon, fifty-eight original Disney animation studio movies,
our estimated total deaths are...
three-hundred and forty-four thousand and thirty one.
Which is honestly nothing compared to the number of childhood dreams this show kills on a regular basis.
(screaming child)
Our overall deadliest Disney movie winner is "Dinosaur" and a death count of up to 300,000 sapient lemurs.
The most deaths of any movie you cared about,
or are likely to have seen
however,
goes resoundingly to Hercules
and Atlantis: The Lost Empire, with over
twenty to thirty thousand deaths each by volcano.
Most deaths in a Disney princess movie,
as well as Disney's deadliest princess goes to "Mulan" with just over twelve-hundred,
very respectable number.
Disney's deadliest and most effective villain is Scar, from "The Lion King",
at sixteen-hundred and fifty-nine deaths.
(The sixteen hundred and sixtieth death was his own.)
Most twisted deaths go to "Alice in Wonderland",
where the walrus eats twelve oyster babies.
Most tragic death ends up going to the accidentally harpooned opera singing whale in "Make Mine Music".
*sigh*
Just brutally sad.
And my personal favorite Disney death goes to Ursula being stabbed in the stomach at the end of "The Little Mermaid".
And now, finally, with this series over and all this being said,
you can now go and we can all collectively kill off 2018 to start the ol' kill count back at zero for 2019.
This has been an incredibly fun but
totally exhausting project to finish off the year.
I hope you enjoyed it as much
as I did. This was a blast.
Let me know if you want me to do something similar for Pixar movies, Dreamworks movies,
I don't know, I'm game for anything.
Thank you so
much for your support over this three-part trilogy.
Thank you so much for
your continued support of Film Theory,
and have a Happy New Year everyone!
Onward to 2019!
I will see you there with more theories.
More Film Theories!
Aaaand cut.